an addiction to distraction is the death
of your creative production if you want
a rose bush to blossom to fully bloom to
become the most they can be you have to
prune away buds turns out most people
spend 70 percent of their life
living in survival and living in stress
so they're they're always anticipating
the worst case scenario based on a past
experience
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the eight
destructive habits that you need to stop
doing right now
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one avoid distraction with robin sharma
an addiction to distraction is the death
of your creative production there is
research coming out now saying that the
average person checks their phone 200 to
500 times every single day
as i share in my book the 5am club your
phone is costing you your fortune if you
look at the great geniuses of the world
the shakespeares and the basquiats and
the beethovens the great chefs and the
great titans of industry and the great
humanitarians all great thinkers have
one thing in common they spent
long periods of time away from
diversions distractions
trivial interruptions
so you can be like the majority being
busy being busy or you can be a history
maker and a legendary producer
and not being on your phone not playing
with technology every second not being
addicted to that white screen you don't
get to do both and i'm going to get
right into the first habit that will
help you beat digital distraction and
that's build your tight bubble of total
focus
so there's a relatively new term coming
out right now called digital dementia
digital dementia we are spending so much
time in front of our screens
that we are
waking up with this full well of
cognitive bandwidth in other words our
gifts and our glory in terms of our
brain's capacity we wake up and we're
ready to go and then what happens is in
terms of digital dementia
we check our phone we check our email we
check for likes we watch a video we play
with an app and every single piece of
attention
that we give
to one of those distractions is stealing
your cognitive bandwidth
this is really important you wake up
full of full of cognitive potential full
of the ability to be creative and
productive and every single time you
check your screen
some of your cognitive bandwidth that's
the term that the researchers and
neuroscientists use is left on the
screen another term is called attention
residue you leave a residue of your
attention on the screen and then you
turn on the news more of your attention
is left on the news and then you check
for email more if that attention residue
is left on the email and then you'll
find it's eight o'clock or nine o'clock
in the morning and you can't focus and
your creativity is depleted well it's
not because you can't bring on your fire
to dominate your domain
it's because you haven't managed
yourself like the pros do and so the
first excellent habit to beat digital
distraction is installing this
metaphorical tight bubble of total focus
around yourself so that you don't let
distractions in just imagine you have
this bubble it's like a five foot bubble
around you it's a porous bubble so
creative things inspirational things
high vibration joyful excellent amazing
people get in
the right spaces get in
and anything that is toxic anything that
is a trivial distraction
which is generally because you're
have an addiction to it we'll talk about
that later in this episode doesn't get
in and so really it's very valuable to
get lost it's very you know most people
are available to everyone the phone
rings and they pick it up and they
answer it well if you do that you're
letting someone else's priorities run
your day versus you running your day by
your priorities
tight bubble of total focus
could also mean that you know you set up
your ecosystem and your environments
so that there's no distraction type
bubble of total focus could mean that
you spend long periods of your day alone
working on those one or two projects
that are your sistine chapel ceilings
habit number two prune away with james
clear if you're someone who does what i
would call half work where you start a
project and work on a little bit and
then never end up finishing it or you're
doing a task and then you leave it
undone you look at an email and you
leave it on red you use your inbox as a
to-do list all these different things
these are open loops that you're opening
in your brain over and over again you
have all this undone work that is taking
up mental energy that's using up space
you can consider your brain kind of like
a it's like ram right like a in a
computer you're at 100 and then you
start to have to remember things and you
drop down to 95 94 and you're taking
yourself down and all of a sudden on
your average day you only have 75 of
your power to put toward a task because
you're so busy trying to remember all
these open loops and things that you are
spending energy on you can only have one
most important thing and the way that we
operate and the way that we divide our
energy and push our energy around has
not changed even if we're defining it in
a different way
so
given that how do we decide what
priorities to focus on how do we decide
what to whittle out and what to cut down
warren buffett has a strategy that i
find relatively interesting and useful
um you know buffett is
probably the most famous investor the
last hundred years and certainly one of
the most successful of all time and uh
this story comes directly from his
personal pilot mike flint who was
telling the story to a friend of mine so
mike flint has been warren buffett's
personal pilot for a while he's also
flown air force one he's flown multiple
u.s presidents um he's an accomplished
guy
and he was telling buffett hey warren
you should really get this new plane
it's pretty sick i'd like to be able to
fly this thing
you should buy this at some point and he
was like i'd love to be able to find
this you know in the next five or ten
years and apparently warren looked at
mike flint and said
if you're still flying for me in 10
years then i probably have failed you as
a boss because you're not growing enough
right you you haven't grown out of this
and if i'm serious about developing you
then we're gonna need to do that so what
i want you to do
is sit down and write the top 25
priorities that you have for yourself
for the next you know 10 or 15 years and
this exercise i'm about to share you can
do this on any timeline right you do 25
priorities for your career you can do 25
for this month 25 for this year whatever
works for you
so mike flynn goes off writes down his
25 priorities he comes back and takes a
look at warren buffett says here's the
list i got it
he says all right good i want you to
circle the top five i want you to focus
on the five priorities that are most
important you go ahead and circle those
take a little bit of time goes off and
does that brings the list back and he's
like okay tell me how you're gonna how
you're gonna deal with this now mike
what are you gonna do he says well
i've selected my top five most important
priorities so i'm going to go ahead and
focus on those and then the rest of this
list will be kind of like my my backup
plan right on weekends or when i have
extra time or when a project stalls i'll
work on the other stuff
and buffett said no no you got it all
wrong
this list of numbers 6 through 25 is
your never do under any circumstance
list
and the reason it took me a while to
like grasp why this is so important the
things that we love that are not the
most important are the easiest to
rationalize spending time on and
distracting us from the things that are
really important right the things that
are good but not great that's the stuff
that ends up taking us off course
it's not that we don't really want
something it's not that we don't really
you know want to improve or we don't
know exactly what the most important
thing is to us it's that we choose to
spend our ways on number six through our
time on number six through 25 too often
we choose to make these rationalizations
for this is a decent use of time not
really wasting time right i'm not
sitting around watching a bad tv show or
something i'm working on something
relatively important but that's the
stuff that pulls away from greatness
so
what i like to think about come back to
that rose bush if i'm not much of a
gardener
but
gardeners tell me that if you want a
rose bush to blossom to fully bloom to
become the most they can be you have to
prune away buds right you can't just let
everything grow on um you know unpruned
and in order to do that that means you
have to cut away buds that could blossom
into something they could become a
full-grown flower they could look good
so these are good ideas that you have to
clip away but you have to bring those
out of your life if you want to truly be
great if you want to focus on
flourishing to the biggest degree habit
number three set standards with brendan
burchard the third big category of bad
habits comes under
placating
placating that means we have a bad habit
of pleasing other people
so that we can cause them less stress
less overwhelm or get less emotional
reaction from them like a lot of people
they're like uh they would call
themselves they say you know brendan i'm
kind of a doormat i said what do you
mean you're a doormat well you know i
just i don't want to cause a ruckus and
i just let people run over me all the
time
you know people are always stepping all
over me
and it's because they have a bad habit
of not fighting for what they really
want not communicating clearly their
expectations not setting standards
instead they don't want to upset their
husband
so they don't say anything it's not
about protection it's about placating
him sometimes it's about placating the
people around you to make them feel good
even though it's coming at the cost of
your life
that's often a big bad habit isn't it
that's why we get overwhelmed in the
first place is because we're doing
everything for everybody else to make
everybody else feel happy and charmed
and good
at the cost of our own sanity our own
well-being our own health all right my
friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world others want
to serve the 25 people closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute to make a
difference to make an impact and this is
your field guide for that habit number
four undo the pattern with gabby
bernstein let's talk about addiction
whether it be food addiction drug
addiction love addiction whatever it may
be
is all the same all addiction has a root
cause condition the root cause often
being
a traumatic event from our childhood
whether we realize it or not whether we
know what it was or not it could have
been a moment of
seeing that we do not have the proper
attachment bond that we needed not
feeling safe with our primary caregivers
not feeling safe in a place where we
were meant to be cared for
any form of
experience that may create a
dissociation within us a place where we
freeze where we lose sight of that
innocence can create an energetic
disturbance within us that we live our
life trying to anesthetize
most people have some form of addiction
whether it be love or drugs or food or
even worrying or fear or gossiping these
are all forms of addiction
we use these different addictive
patterns as a way of numbing
the
terrifying fear
of what it would be
to face that true energetic disturbance
of what may be there
now from an internal family systems
perspective ifs
let's thank your addiction
let's thank the part of you that is the
food addict who has been suffering and
let's thank her right now
because she's she's had an important
role and while her role is extreme
and while today in your highest self in
your adult resourced gorgeous divine
spiritual self you are becoming ready to
allow this part of you to be less
extreme
we have to honor her first
for her extreme role and how she's
protected you
because whether we like it or not the
addictive pattern has been a form of
protection it's been protecting you from
something that you have not been ready
to face that you have not been safe
enough to face that you have whatever
that may be
so let's start by cleaning the slate and
saying thank you to that part to the
addictive part an addictive part of us
is often an ifs known as a firefighter
when we have an old wound or an old fear
or an old trigger or an old trauma
activated and triggered we go to the
food we go to the drink we go to the
work we go to the love whatever it is to
be in a firefighter mode i gotta go put
the fire out i have to protect that
little part of me from feeling that
feeling at all costs and in your case
i'm gonna go eat got it
got it
so this awareness is step one this
awareness this acceptance this love
compassion for this part this part has
had a role it has had a perfect role it
has had purpose it has had meaning it
has meant to really show up for you in a
way that will greatly
look back and we'll say thank you thank
you for being there
that's step one
okay
you've already taken step two which is
having the willingness to change
the willingness and the bravery
to start to look at it to start to
address it
to start to become more conscious and
aware of that part what happens when
we're in the firefighter part the
addictive part
is we dissociate we check out
we we use it to check out
so we may not actually realize that
we're doing it until it's done but if we
can start to slowly recognize the moment
when we're in the binge or we're in the
alcoholism or we're in the pattern if
you can start to create a little
molecule of space
to notice what you notice
in the binge in the moment and just
simply ask yourself one simple question
what does that young part of me need to
feel right now
giving her
permission
to feel in that moment even if it's for
a
molecule moment
a split second is the beginning of the
undoing of the pattern habit number five
don't respond to negative thoughts with
joe dispenza the stronger the emotional
reaction
you have to some experience in your life
the higher the emotional quotient the
more you pay attention to the cause and
the moment the brain puts all of its
attention on the cause it takes a
snapshot and that's called a memory so
long-term memories are created from very
highly um
emotional experiences
so what happens then is that people
think neurologically within the
circuitry of that experience
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions
and so
when you have an emotional reaction to
someone or something most people think
that they can't control their emotional
reaction
well it turns out if you allow that
emotional reaction is called a
refractory period to last for hours or
days
that's called the mood
say to someone hey what's up he said i'm
in a mood why are you in a mood well i
had this thing happen to me five days
ago and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
if you keep that same emotional reaction
going on for weeks or months that's
called temperament
why is he so bitter i don't know let's
ask him why is he so bitter why are you
bitter well i had this thing happen to
me nine months ago
and if you keep that same emotional
reaction going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and so learning how to shorten your
refractory period of emotional reactions
is really where the work starts
so then
people when they have an event what they
do is they keep recalling the event
because the emotions of stress hormones
their survival emotions are saying pay
attention to what happened
because you want to be prepared if it
happens again
turns out most people spend 70 percent
of their life
living in survival and living in stress
so they're they're always anticipating
the worst case scenario based on a past
experience and they're literally
out of the infinite potentials in the
quantum field they're selecting the
worst possible outcome and they're
beginning to emotionally embrace it with
fear and they're conditioning
their body into a state of fear do that
enough times
body has a panic attack without you you
can't even predict it because it's
programmed subconsciously so then
you say to the person why are you this
way
and they'll say i am this way because of
this event that happened to me 15 or 20
years ago
and what that means from biological
standpoint is that they haven't been
able to change since that event
so then the emotions from the experience
tend to give the body and the brain a
rush of energy
so people become addicted to the rush of
those emotions and they use the problems
and conditions in their life to reaffirm
their limitation so at least they can
feel something so now when it comes time
to change you say the person why are you
this way well every time they recall the
event they're producing the same
chemistry in their brain and body as if
the event is occurring firing and wiring
the same circuits
and sending the same emotional signature
to the body well what's the relevance
behind that well your body is the
unconscious mind it doesn't know the
difference between the experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that you're creating by thought alone so
the body's believing
is living in the same past experience 24
hours a day 7 days a week 365 days a
year
and so then when those emotions
influence certain thoughts and they do
and then those thoughts create the same
emotions and those same emotions
influence the same thoughts now the
entire person's state of being is in the
past
so then
the hardest part about change
is not making the same choice as you did
the day before period
and the moment you decide to make a
different choice get ready because it's
going to feel uncomfortable it's going
to feel unfamiliar it's there's going to
be some uncertainty i think that the
bigger thing is that we we keep firing
and wiring those circuits they become
more hardwired so there you have a
thought and then the program runs
but it's the emotion that follows the
thought if you have a if you have a
fearful thought you're going to feel
anxiety the moment you feel anxiety your
brain is checking in with your body and
saying yeah you're pretty anxious so
then you start thinking more
corresponding thoughts equal how you
feel
well the redundancy of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
so now when it comes time to change
a person steps into that river of change
and they make a different choice and all
of a sudden
they don't they they they don't feel the
same way
so the body says well you've been doing
this for 35 years
you're going to just stop feel suffering
and stop feeling guilty and stop feeling
shameful and you're not going to
complain or blame or make excuses or
feel sorry for yourself well
the body's in the unknown so the body
says i want to return back to familiar
territory so the body starts influencing
the mind and it says start tomorrow
you're too much like your mother you'll
never change this isn't going to work
for you this doesn't feel right
and so if you respond to that thought
as if it's true that same thought will
lead to the same choice which will lead
to the same behavior which will create
the same experience which will produce
the same emotion habit number six make
familiar with marissa peer you are
hardwired and super coded
to run away from what is unfamiliar and
to run back to what is familiar
what does that mean well it means that
500 years ago what made you safe
what guaranteed that you could survive
on the planet was staying with the
familiar
and avoiding the unfamiliar nobody who
lived in a walled city or indeed a fort
in the wild west would go out for a walk
late at night to go oh i think i'm going
to meet some new people i'm a bit bored
what made you safe was same old same old
same food same people same environment
and your primitive mind understands this
the familiar makes me safe
and if you've ever seen two-year-old
kids they'll say i don't like that it's
got lumps in it i don't want that it's
different that's the wrong spoon the
wrong cup the wrong story they only like
one doll one teddy they want the same
story every night they won't eat stuff
they don't know or recognize because
their primitive mind at the age of two
says if you only eat well you already
know you'll make it
and now 25 years pass and we find
ourselves liking the same
type of person destructive a
heartbreaker
absent
we find ourselves going for what's
familiar
and nothing makes this more clear than
this study
70 of lottery winners
will go bankrupt in three years
if they haven't had a familiar
relationship with money if they've only
ever just made enough to pay the bills
and had nothing left
then they will find it very hard to
invest that money and keep that money
so
how do you get around that well first of
all understand it okay
i've sat on the couch for so long eating
potato chips and watching tv
i've forgotten that my body's designed
to run and jump and move i've had my
heart broken so many times that i now
just expect that
every job i'm in has never worked out so
it is an absolute fact that you are
hardwired and supercoded to go back to
what you know
and avoid what you don't know
but here's another fact
you can make anything you like familiar
i've seen this the most in such a simple
thing will come into my office and i
might say
oh that's a lovely coat oh i've had it
for seven years got a hole in it or oh i
heard you were the best salesperson in
your team not really it was just a
stroke of luck
i've seen this at the lower end and
right at the top oh
i love that movie you made no it wasn't
very good it won an oscar
i know there were no good nominations
that year
but your second movie won an oscar i
know there were even
worse nominations that year
i hear you written the best-selling book
oh that's just a fluke i don't know how
that came about and i have to sort of go
oh do you see what's happening here
i am praising you
not only are you rejecting the praise
you're adding in criticism you know why
in your life praise was unfamiliar
guess what was familiar of course you
know being criticized and now
your brain is so keen to run back to
what it knows that
it rejects praise
and adds in criticism
i just took in eight cats are about to
be euthanized tiny kittens and i saw
with them that i had to hold them every
day and go okay
we're gonna make being stroked familiar
we're gonna make being held familiar and
very quickly they would line my arms
like babies if i hadn't touched them
they would have been feral
so and that happens with babies if you
hold a baby that's never held they go
rigid
they have attachment disorder if you
don't have love or praise or money or
success
you start to reject it so how do you get
around that first way your mind
sabotages you
do this you go i am making praise
i am making success i'm making taking
sugar out of my coffee familiar i'm
making going to the gym or doing some
stretches at home or really believing in
myself a million never add if it kills
me
because the last thing i do just say i'm
making it familiar
and as you do that make all the negative
stuff unfamiliar being down on yourself
diminishing yourself
criticizing yourself make praise
familiar
criticism unfamiliar that
on its own i promise you
will change your entire life how about
number seven use i don't affirmations
with marie forleo a few weeks ago
during a company meeting someone asked
for some ideas to break a late night
cookies and ice cream habit this person
said and i quote it's like i turn into a
child at 9pm and i have to have my
cookies and my ice cream before bed this
needs to stop
and i mean i could relate i don't think
that there is any human on the planet
who at any given time doesn't have at
least one habit that really needs to get
kicked to the curb
well it turns out that there's a simple
two word fix that can dramatically
increase our ability to resist
temptation and it gives us a better
chance to make a better choice now this
is based on research done by dr vanessa
patrick she's a professor of marketing
at the university of houston who
published her findings on the power of
self-talk in the journal of consumer
research
she found that when participants framed
a refusal as i don't for instance i
don't eat chocolate cake or i don't eat
sugar instead of i can't they were more
successful at resisting the desire to
eat unhealthy foods or skip the gym
in fact they found that when it came to
deciding whether to eat certain foods
saying i don't was nearly three times as
effective as saying no and about eight
times more effective than saying i can't
very interesting right
i don't versus i can't two teeny tiny
words that can make a ginormous
difference and here's why when we say i
don't we are empowered we're determined
we are at choice it's a tough strong
phrase like end of story but when we say
i can't we disempower ourselves it
sounds like we're not allowed to do
something by some outside force you know
what we make ourselves feel deprived
when we say i can't and in essence we
make ourselves weak whiny little [ __ ]
like wow
i can't have a
now what's even cooler though is that we
can tuck this little trick into every
corner of our lives we can start making
some clear strong declarations like this
i don't eat skinny pop every night and
habit number eight the last one before
some very special bonus clips is stay
away from negativity with dean graziosi
every year i go back to new york and i
sponsor a golf tournament where um
uh money goes to make a wish foundation
and a lot of other people in need and
it's fun i sponsor it or one of the
biggest sponsors and then the next day i
actually go pheasant hunting i do it
once a year i think it's pretty awesome
don't worry all the birds get eaten and
if you're not a hunter i'm sorry but uh
it's fun
okay so but while i was there one of the
one of the rituals the yearly rituals
i've been doing this about six years now
is when i land we land at the airport i
drive straight to my favorite italian
restaurant called chenna 2000 it's down
in the river in newburgh new york great
italian restaurant
and i meet my buddies there buddies that
i knew since fifth grade um and every
year
you know it's kind of a reality check
it's a little tiny town we lived in in
upstate new york above newburgh about 15
miles above newburgh
went to high school with 110 kids right
um
so i went to dinner and i realized and
this is in no way
disrespecting my friends or talking bad
about them but i realized as the years
go by
their conversations get more negative
and more negative so i sat down with
them
and i realized that
every time something good was brought up
10 things negative were brought up you
know even one of my friends literally
said he's like you know what i realized
recently the day you're born is the day
you start dying you know somebody talk
about somebody getting married and
someone say yeah but you hear so and so
is cheating talk about somebody you know
winning at an election yeah but you hear
so-and-so died every time i brought up
something positive or even if somebody
else did there was ten things negative
and it made me realize these are people
i love and care about and have known
forever and i was trying and here's what
i want to tell you for years without
them even realizing this sounds like i'm
putting myself above them and i don't
mean that i just think a little
different than most people i would try
to insert bigger future things right so
we're not talking about hey the good old
days and now it sucks right we're
talking about hey we had the good old
days let's have some good better days in
the future and i would insert it and
sometimes i'd get the conversation on a
fun positive note well this is the first
year that i noticed i couldn't spin it
the economy is bad the president's bad
the country's bad everything bad bad bad
bad bad
so
when i left there i was kind of sad that
i couldn't spin it and and that i can't
let my friends people i care about see
what that what comes out of their mouth
is the life they live right i don't want
to get into that again because i know
i've done it in earlier blogs but what
we say every day is the life we live if
we think we live in a horrible country
the president's horrible the congress is
horrible the economy is horrible if we
think all that is horrible which whether
it is or not if we think that
that's the life we live every day if we
focus on the negative news if we focus
what's wrong with things not what's
right if we focus that yesterday was
better than tomorrow can be that's the
life we live now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you now
one of the things i see in a lot of
entrepreneurs is they have a negative
attitude that they hold on to where if
you want to win you got to embrace the
other side you got to let go of the
negativity let go of the negative people
the mindset the belief system that's
holding you where you are and so that's
the point in this video we're going to
talk about the seven ways to destroy
your negative attitude when somebody's
coming at you with with a ton of
negativity try to step above it
and just have empathy for their
situation just try to take the words
that they're throwing at you that may be
really negative and insulting and
hurtful and just like imagine you have
this invisible shield on you that just
like
reflects it right or like your matrix
style like it's just going over you you
don't feel it or the words bounce off
and fall on the floor just just try to
avoid the words for a few seconds and
just try to think about that person
think about their life think about the
mindset think about where they're coming
from and think would you want their life
like if you know them if there's
somebody close to you
you it's easy to do you know their life
think do you want their life
you know if they're 75 years old and
never got to follow their dream and they
were hating on you for following your
dream like would do you want to trade
spot do you want to be that person do
you want to be 75 years old and have
tried your dream and failed and never
got the chance or never took the chance
to go do it again like you don't want
that person's life so you don't want
anything to do with how they think
and so having a little bit of empathy
for where they're coming from allows you
to shift your perspective to say okay
that's why this person is so hateful
like look at their life
if you don't know the person then just
just imagine it so i do this or i did
this a lot in the early days of my
youtube channel when i got a hate
comment when somebody would hate on my
video not not because of anything wrong
with the video they just they hated on
me or they hated on the person i was
profiling or they hated another person
leaving a comment on the channel
and at the start it really bothered me
and i tried to shift the perspective and
i tried to work with them
or i got really combative
and now i always leave from a place of
empathy like can you imagine somebody
coming to your channel leaving an
absolutely hateful comment
and that's how they get satisfaction
like that's how they get a little boost
in their day
the thing that gives them a little bit
of energy in the day is is hating on
somebody else's youtube videos
or hating on somebody else's creative
expression
how bad does your life have to be that
that's the highlight of your day
and i just try to imagine this person
what their life looks like and how i
would never want to step into that
person's life how bad an environment
they must have right now
and so i feel sorry for them
and having that empathy can remove the
sting of the words because you still see
the words but if you have a little
context of what's behind the words then
it's less likely to actually sting you
even though they're saying the same
words when you start talking about my
brain
it's an organ it's like your heart is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can
you know speed up the brain waves in
your brain you can slow them down you
can tune in you can tune out yeah we
haven't been given the user's manual for
the most powerful tools we're aware of
that's right
and so the great news you know i know
you being an athlete and a successful
businessman you have discipline you
cannot
you can't achieve research she results
without some kind of discipline
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and jim rohn is i know you
you love generally so you either pay the
price of discipline or you pay the price
of regret discipline weighs ounces
regret weighs tons that's good but the
the thing is can you teach discipline
the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant
and if the participants reason why
is big enough if they know i want to
achieve x
and the reason why the motive for their
action motivation the motive for their
action
is a reason beyond just themselves
chances are they will do more
to achieve that success than if it was
just left up to their own but there are
some people that are born
you know with incredible drive they just
have this insatiable drive and they'll
just i'll do whatever it takes
for the things that i want and there's
other people that want things but they
just don't have this insatiable drive
and this is where you know i as much as
i hated school i love to use schools and
analogy yeah in the game of life whether
it's health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level of the
game do i want to play at
is it the great school level the
kindergarten level the high school level
the university level the pro level
because each one of those levels
requires a totally different mindset and
totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse
and drill and fall and fail forward to
the next attempt you will never make it
as a pro you will never make as a pro
business person you'll never make it as
a pro husband or wife or athlete or
musician you just never will so just get
used to that if you're not prepared to
pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude and the talent now
we're talking about there's some real
potential here
and what we don't know is you know
what's in your heart like what is the
fire that stirs you that that you wake
up saying i will do this even when i
don't feel like it i will do whatever it
takes to overcome my temptation for
mediocracy my temptation for excuses my
temptation for
reasons and circumstances to hold me
back i won't allow those to be in my way
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose right and so
the question you asked before is how do
you develop that start small yeah start
small
so if you
don't have discipline show do you show
yourself that you can give yourself one
command and one follow-through so you
know what
right now i'm going to get up i'm going
to do two push-ups
right now not not like later now can you
give yourself a simple command one
sit-up right now i'm going to go get a
glass of water you start with something
ridiculous i learned many years ago
reduce it to the ridiculous
so for reduce it to the ridiculousness i
start i said can you do that
great will you
because that's the difference right
there
is that's the razor's edge the people
who can will you will you yeah great
when now now yeah right so if you
develop that skill and specifically from
a brain plasticity a neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that you
give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern that you can
give yourself a command and take action
now that maybe just be one time
well what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you were if my
computer was open i'd have um every hour
it would say it's twelve o'clock it's
one o'clock and i take sixty seconds
just to be in control of my mind
sixty-seven i don't care where i stop
what you're doing stop take six breaths
just get it just get centered am i on
track am i off track am i doing
something i shouldn't be doing versus a
high impact activity that i need to be
doing
every hour i've trained myself to just
reset
i didn't always do that so i just
started with
one a day right then two sure then three
then it was working so well i said great
let's do this every hour i talk to so
many smart fantastic ambitious
idealistic hard-working kids and they're
right out of college they're in their
entry-level jobs and i'll ask them how's
it going and they'll say
i think i'm gonna quit
and i'm like why
they say to me
i'm not making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you
find joy from
is not something you discover it's not
like i found love
here it is i found a job i love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable
object that doesn't mean you have to do
your time that's not what i'm talking
about
take a helicopter climb i don't care but
there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dumping on to the next ghost
and on to the next and i at the time
this was early on you know because when
i first started making money and it was
you know my salary
or my earnings were
published all over the place i mean the
first year i was like really did i make
that much money oh my god um
it was very difficult for me to figure
out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything
so it's easy when you don't have
anything and people ask you for money
they say i need 500 you say i don't have
it because i'm just trying to get my
rent paid
it's harder when your
multi-billion dollar salary is now in
the paper and you get a lot of friends
and cousins you didn't have before
[Music]
so how do you set
boundaries for yourself i was having
trouble setting boundaries myself for
myself for even strangers people would
just show up at my door in chicago and
say oh bro i left my husband please help
me
and i would because she knows i haven't
so
don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that
oh the reason why people keep showing up
is because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that
you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm gonna
say yes i'm gonna say yes so when stevie
called me this time i thought i'd try
out my first no on stevie let's start
big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because
i have my own charities and i care about
a lot of people but the the problem is
when you you have money everybody thinks
you just want to give to everything so
every letter i ever get starts with we
know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um
as a person who has that disease to
please i was waiting for him then just
to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a song for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay
okay it's okay he said okay check you
later
and
[Music]
what i learned from that is
many times you will have angst and worry
about things
and
put yourself in a state like someone
said this morning because their phone
went off they were mortified over a
phone i said really um you will put
yourself in a state when the other
person really isn't even thinking about
you
so
learning that i could
specifically determine for myself what
the boundaries were for me
what i wanted to do
give my money give my time give of my
service to who i wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week doesn't mean you
have to try to fulfill all of that just
because you have all of these demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said in invictus and
understanding that really changed the
meaning of my life in that i was not
no longer driven by what
other people wanted me to do
but took charge of my own destiny making
choices based upon what do i feel
is the next right move for me every
notice that some people seem to want to
hang on to stuff that is bothering them
they're forever talking about it they
don't want to let it go they've had a a
failure at something and it's drone they
can't get over it they just can't get
over or somebody said something nasty to
them they don't want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you
i want you to think about this i'm not
going to talk about a lot about this
today because i don't think i have to i
just want to let you know that if you're
holding on to something that does not
serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
it's you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
you know the beautiful part about having
an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you i physically stress my body
to extremes because i've
developed a process to take people and
help them change in a weekend but my
idea of the weekend is 50 hours and most
people won't sit for a three-hour movie
so uh you know that somebody spent 300
million dollars on and i got 12 000
people in a stadium i got back from last
night up in san jose we had four days
and nights like this
and we actually had a halter on me and a
group of researchers that worked with
olympic athletes and i burned 9 500
calories in one day in nine hours the
battery died before i finished i i went
12 hours um i did
uh i burned enough calories for two
marathons my jumps because i'm jumping
constantly with the equivalent of two
nba games uh
my lactate as you all know at one is
hard to talk it was 14 and i was still
going strong at 12 hours so there's some
physical stress because
i'm a believer that talking is that you
got to go deep you got to get people to
experience things i think a belief is a
poor substitute for an experience and if
i get someone experience changing
something if i can do it in a really
potent way where they really feel it
then you know if you do that over and
again you start to get someone actually
trained to get a new result it's not
about belief uh you know belief is
important it's not about confidence i
heard that kind of description that's
never bullets but it's strategy but if
you don't have the certainty you're not
going to execute so i think i've spent a
lifetime accumulating patterns there are
patterns we all have they're patterns
that make you angry patterns that make
you sad patterns make you excited
patterns that make you grateful
um patterns in health as you well know
so like all of you who are the best at
what you do i'm massively into pattern
recognition
pattern utilization and pattern creation
let me first explain to you what
forgiveness isn't because most people
won't forgive because they have an
incorrect understanding of what
forgiveness is
so forgiveness is not
pardoning someone's behavior it's not
excusing someone's behavior forgiveness
isn't admitting that you were wrong
forgiveness isn't saying what was done
to me is okay
forgiveness isn't any of those things
forgiveness actually
if you really understand it it has less
to do with the other person and more to
do with you
and more to do with your future let's go
back to the oil and water scenario
so forgiveness invites in love
invites in possibility invites in
prosperity it invites in new thinking it
invites in creativity so forgiveness is
an expanding emotion when you forgive
you're opened up for new things
anger is a contracting emotion it
requires you to shut down to avoid to
shut out to stop talking everything in
anger is about stopping and shutting
down
everything about forgiveness is about
opening up without pardoning someone's
behavior i want to make sure i'm clear
on that because most people attach
forgiveness to but you don't know what
he did but you don't know what she did
when you can detach forgiveness is not
about what they did
forgiveness get this forgiveness is
about making yourself available think
about you your body is primary real
estate there's only so much of it it's a
finite it's a finite
space there's only so much space it's
not forever but if this is your body
this so if this is your primary real
estate
if this is your primary real estate your
heart
and your you have anger occupying 20 of
it you can never experience a hundred
percent love you can never experience a
hundred percent possibility you haven't
given yourself a chance
at a hundred percent of the things you
want most because your primary real
estate your heart your body your mind is
being occupied with a very intrusive
toxic emotion
less and less about them
nothing to do with them being right or
their behavior being pardoned or the
action it's your your future is paying
for your past
when you hold on to anger
so when you get really connected to the
cost of anger
then it's not about the what
a matter of fact the longer you've been
angry the longer you've robbed yourself
of a hundred percent of what you were
worthy of and if someone's betrayed you
if someone's hurt you then you over
everyone deserve a hundred percent love
a hundred percent possibility a hundred
percent but it requires forgiveness
and in many cases it's forgiveness of
yourself in many cases the person you've
been angry at the longest is yourself
and the same rule applies when it comes
to you so what is envy and we actually
is more of a
expression of how we feel about
ourselves rather than how we're
perceiving someone else it's actually so
much more about how comfortable we feel
with who we are how confident we feel
with who we are how much self-esteem we
have how much self-assurance we have
enemy is more a root of that than it is
of the fact that someone else is doing
well it's less about the fact that
someone out there is amazing making
waves doing something that you want to
be doing it's more about how we feel
about ourselves and it's experienced
in that way of looking at someone else
and reflecting back on us social circles
family circles someone else has done
amazingly in their exams someone just
landed a new job someone else just got
promoted and everyone's looking at you
going what are you doing right what have
you achieved where where are you today
where have you got right what's
happening with you tell us about you
and you're thinking you know you're
going through all your head you're
trying to come up with all the things
that you've thought about all the things
that you've achieved all the things that
you've done and you're trying to bring
it up like constantly but you're
struggling you find it hard because
you're now measuring your growth
based on someone else's you're now
measuring your success based on someone
else's and that is the
biggest challenge with envy now one of
the biggest challenges it brings in our
life is that it forces us to start
measuring our sex
sorry our success
in comparison to someone else's that is
the biggest challenge with envy
when we start comparing the level of our
success with someone else's you're
already on the wrong foot i have several
people in my life friends and relatives
who i want to support but after i spend
time with them i feel trained
sometimes i avoid them but then i feel
guilty and can only avoid them for so
long
can you explain why i feel this way and
what advice you have for me
uh thank you for your question erica and
i think this is something that a lot of
people face and i'm not sure how to
approach
basically i mean the way to look at it
is that we only have so much energy each
day when we go to sleep we wake up in
the morning we have for example this
much energy and throughout the day we we
use that energy we give that energy to
people and things around us and by the
end of the day that energy gets less and
less and less and then until the end of
the day where there's
almost nothing left and you feel tired
and you go to sleep again one of the
things you have to understand is that
some people fill you with energy and
some people drain you of energy the
people that drain you of energy i like
to call them energy vampires and there
are a lot of them and sometimes these
people are colleagues their
friends their relatives even close
family members one of the important
things to do is really identify someone
as
a temporary energy vampire or are they
inherently an energy vampire so what i
mean by that is someone is temporarily
an energy vampire i mean that
they're going through a difficult time
in their life if somebody in the family
has died or going through the law so
some big challenging experience and for
a few months or
maybe a couple of years they're
energetically draining but it's okay you
know you love them they're your friend
their family member you want to support
them and you can put up with that for a
little time in your life
but someone is inherently an energy
vampire you know they've always been
their whole life every time you meet
with them you encounter them you feel
completely drained then it's really
important to take note of that that's a
personality trait that's not going to
change anytime soon unless
they're actively working on it and most
energetic most energy vampires don't
really want to work on themselves in
nature
so one of the things to do here at this
point is to
identify these people one of the ways to
identify these people is that when you
spend time with someone
and as soon as you have a conversation
with them after spending time with them
when you walk away as soon as you turn
around and walk away ask yourself do you
feel uplifted or do you feel drained
and that's
immediately you'll know as soon as you
turn around and walk away you feel
uplifted you'll go like wow that was
such a great conversation i got so much
out of it i feel so inspired you know
then that person uplifted you but if you
walk away and you feel completely
draining going oh my god that was so
exhausting
then
chances are that person is an energy
vampire and especially if you meet that
person 15 20 times a year and just so
you met the person 20 times a year
and out of that 20 times a year 19 of
those were extremely exhausting
conversations then
you can quite very well qualify you can
easily qualify that that person
is an energy vampire and you want to
avoid them you don't really want people
in your life the way to look at it is so
that if you're working so hard on
yourself
to improve yourself to be a better
person then why allow someone else to
come and dream your way it's for example
an entrepreneur who built his business
from nothing
would never allow somebody to come in
and destroy his business your real self
knows the truth no matter what mask or
what face you wear in the world your
real self knows the truth and there was
a time in my life when i acted like i
knew a truth that i didn't know and the
truth i didn't know
was the depth of my value and my worth
you see i had already been an author
that had sold over 6 million books
14 different titles i had already been
on my own television show i had traveled
around the world i had spoken to
hundreds of thousands of people and
still i did not know or value
my own worth so in a very big
opportunity to go forward and to be on
what was once called the oprah winfrey
show
yes and i went on the oprah winfrey show
and miss winfrey asked me back again and
again and again and eventually i became
part of her change your life faculty and
it was all good i had written 13 books i
had traveled all over the country i had
done her show repeatedly but i didn't
know
my own sense of worth
so what happened i tried to live in a
place that i didn't believe was true for
me and eventually i crashed and burned
crashed and burned by leaving the oprah
winfrey show and going on to another
network and doing another show that
didn't even survive a season all because
i didn't know my work now it would have
looked like
all sorts of external circumstances oh
there was a miscommunication between me
and miss winfrey and the other network
was offering me a lot of money and why
shouldn't i take a big business deal no
it was about me not knowing my own worth
me not being able to stand
in the miracle
of being on the oprah winfrey show
repeatedly among honored teachers
without having to work hard for it
because that was what i had been taught
the matter with me was that i didn't
know how to receive a gift a blessing
without working hard for it so when
things came to me easily i blew them up
it's self-sabotage or procrastination or
forgetting or whatever it is that
opportunity went away because i didn't
know my work that's the kind of truth we
have to tell each other we have to be
aware of it we have to acknowledge it
and we have to accept it and then we
have to look at what makes me
live less than my truth for those of you
that feel very overwhelmed because of
home work side hustle
and your woman
you probably also feel guilty about
taking time to work on your side hustle
that's because women girls we are raised
to be good girls for raise to be good
daughters for raised to uh be seen and
not heard we're raised to take care of
people it's socialized into you and you
see your mothers by the way also
sacrifice everything to take care of
everybody else and to put themselves
laps this is a learned behavior so if
you
also are a woman you probably feel
guilty for taking time for yourself stop
that you have to stop that
the reason why you have to stop that is
first of all if you're a mom you've got
to show your daughters and your sons
what it looks like to pursue your dreams
secondly
as a woman you're not going to get what
you want if you're constantly putting
guilt on yourself for taking time for
yourself and third the only way you will
discover the power and potential inside
of you is if you push that generation
to the side and you actually realize
that your life is for you
that your mom you know why she
sacrificed everything she did because
she wanted you to pursue your dreams so
knock it off with the guilt because the
guilt is also contributing to the
overwhelm the guilt is making you not
talk to your partner or your boss or
your colleagues or your friends about
what you need for support the guilt is
adding weight to
you not being able to carve out the time
and be disciplined to find the time for
yourself and so it has got to go you
hear me get rid of it before i start
this journey be navy seal i go back to
see my dad because i realize now i gotta
fix some
i'm blaming everything
i gotta go back you know how a lot of
times like
if you're a runner your your your right
knee may hurt
but it's not your right knee that hurts
it's where your left hip yes but we're
concentrating on the right knee
i'm concentrating on all my
but i need to go back to the root of the
problem which is my dad
i gotta face the demon
i gotta go back and see what made him so
[ __ ] up to make me so why am i [ __ ]
up
so i go back and i and i go back in as a
as an older man now i'm in my 20s i'm
not a kid anymore and i want to see this
man and face him as a as a as a grown
man
but still as a kid in my head i was
still a kid but i was a grown man as my
age
i went back and i realized he was the
same man that he was still the same
still the same
and i talked to him he was still nuts
and um
but i i had to go back and face that one
more time but to face it in a different
way how'd you do it differently
i looked at him in a way we never said
sorry to one another and he went off
about my mom and my grandparents and all
kind of i looked at him in a way
that i realized now why you [ __ ] this
up
i had to almost be him
to realize it's okay brother
it's okay because i realized that
somewhere in your life
something [ __ ] you up and you didn't
deal with it
and so you put it on me my mom and
everybody around you
i'm going to deal with my
wow so even though you gave me all this
you you gave me a satchel that i didn't
deserve and now i'm all [ __ ] up and
people think i'm a liar and i'm all
[ __ ] up you gave me this you created
this nightmare of goggins
i'm gonna fix it though i have have a
son who suffers from a mental illness
bipolar
and many times like during this period
in the last few months he
has decided he don't want to take his
medication i don't care how old your
kids
become he's 35 they're always your
children so not only does it keep me up
at night
but it keeps me singing a song you about
to make me lose my butt up in here up in
here you've got to make me act
up in here
i remember one night somebody called me
say are you on facebook i said no
go to yourself facebook and here they're
saying
i've spent more money on marijuana than
i have on self-development i'm mrs mamie
brown's grandson
let me tell you something
i needed some weed after watching him
so you know the lie said fake it not
strange that you have faced the fiery
furnaces of this world
it has been a humbling experience that
i've been able to motivate and inspire
young men around the world and my son
looked like i had him by myself that i
can't reach him
and so
i have learned lord grant me the
serenity to accept the things that i
cannot change i can't change him the
courage to change the things that i care
i can change how i react how i respond
and the courage to know the difference
and so
i've learned to discipline myself to let
go and let god and once letting go don't
go back to god and get it just give it
to it
yes yes that our kids come through us
but they come from god and learn to
surrender life is about surrendering
and releasing
and i've learned the discipline to do
that
because it hasn't been easy treat
yourself
like you're someone that you care about
i read this this
piece of work by jung a long while back
and he it was a meditation on
um the injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated something like that and what
jung pointed out which i really liked
was that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people
it was an invitation to reciprocity it
was something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated
like you were taking care of yourself
not how you would like people to respond
to you it's more important than that
it's like imagine you had a child that
you really cared for
and and someone said well
people will treat this child exactly
like you want them to but you have to
figure out what that is and so then
you'd have to sit down for like a month
and you'd think okay well how do you
want your child to be treated you don't
want everyone just to be nice to him you
know you want people to challenge him
and you want people to discipline him
and you want people to tell him when
he's wrong it's like you don't just want
everyone to be nice that's that's
pathetic it's pathetic isn't there's no
challenge in that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and well you'd like people to fawn all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's that's not something you'd wish
for for someone that you were taking
care of and then then there's an
additional problem which is it's often
the case that people will treat other
people better than they treat themselves
that happens extremely
frequently so one of the things i
pointed out chapter two was that if you
have a dog and you take him to a vet and
the vet gives you your prescription
medicine you'll go buy the medicine and
you will give it to the dog and you will
do it properly but if you go yourself to
a doctor and you get a prescription
there's one that there's a 30 chance you
won't even pick up the medication
and if you do there's a 50 chance that
you won't administer it to yourself
properly
and so i really thought about that when
i first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts i thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously you'll do it for
something you care about and you're
conscientious enough so you'll actually
do it so like why wouldn't you do it for
you your dog likes you you know even
your dog would rather that you did but
but you don't you don't and and it's
actually one of the reasons that modern
medicine doesn't work nearly as well as
it could because people just don't take
their medication you make the world a
much better place a much worse place if
you don't take care of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapters about it's
partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that western
civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark
and so it's
not just so that you feel better and not
just so that you're a number one lobster
not none of those things you need to
take care of yourself because you're in
the best position to do that and it's
necessary for you to take care of
yourself despite the fact that we're
mortal and vulnerable and self-conscious
and capable not only capable of doing
terrible things but actually do them
despite all that
you you're still you still have that
responsibility i think the reason why
some wealthy people and even lottery
winners we see the suicide rates amongst
lottery winners they they end up being
miserable
is because the reason
because of their relationship with money
but the reason why they wanted money
maybe the reason why they were pursuing
it maybe the way they glamorized it in
their own mind on the path there was
heavily extrinsically motivated and they
in some respect thought that some
magical confetti was going to rain down
on them when they made that billion or
you know and so it's going to be this
internal feeling of euphoria and i just
think the the lack of it the the
anti-climaxes
sets you off on this spiral of maybe
it's prostitutes maybe it's cocaine
maybe it's lamb maybe it's you know
far-flying business class maybe and
they're chasing something that doesn't
exist they're chasing off the pleasure
like a mirage in a desert like a
watering hole in a desert getting closer
and closer and it's moving off into the
distance and they just keep faster
whereas michael burch the guy was so
grounded and so happy with himself he
made a billion and was like
i've got my wife sochi i love her my
life's good
yeah don't need to chase anything i am
already enough i think that's probably
the the most powerful three words
that like that most profound and most
simple three words that's something i'm
enough said said this one sent me one
day they said um
they said what if you're you are already
enough
and
it's so simple right but it just
shatters everything it shatters every s
programming i had as a kid you got to
climb the ladder you've got to you know
piss you that chase that you do this
constant pursuit of something right that
the words that maybe what if just
imagine for a second you are already
enough the suppression the repression of
healthy anger
is a major risk factor for illness it
actually suppresses the immune system
for reasons that i will tell you later
so there's
basically
three ways of dealing with anger
one is to repress it like this woman did
so these are the people that are always
nice you know they're always nice
i worry about really nice
people the other way is to
give into it and to act it odd to to go
into rages that's also unhealthy the
first the repression of anger leads to
autoimmune disease and cancer
the
when you're raging all the time that
increases your risk of heart disease and
strokes
so in the aftermath the studies have
shown that in the aftermath of a rage
episode your risk of a heart attack
doubles for the next two
hours then there's the healthy of
expression of anger
or the healthy
processing of anger which most of us
don't know how to do
we either do the one or we do the other
i'll talk to you about healthy anger
later but how do we deal with anger uh
is is has a crucial effect on our health
and uh this guy writes you know she had
no ego she just blended in with the
environment in an unassuming manner and
this is supposed to be a good thing now
my wife's name is ray and she's an
artist and it's one of her paintings
that provided the detail here on the
cover and the color scheme for the cover
for this book
and sometimes i say to ray you know we
were married 42 years why can't you
blend in with the environment
in an unassuming man in an unassuming
manner
but ray has done her psychological work
and she's read my book and
she's also seen the studies you know
there was a study
just four or five years ago presented at
a major medical conference they looked
at 1700 women over a 10-year period and
over a 10-year period out of these women
those who who were unhappily married and
suppressed their feelings
were four times as likely to die as
those who were also unhappily married
but expressed their feelings
so the issue wasn't
happy marriage or unhappy marriage the
issue was did the woman express herself
or did she not
so
when i come to this point at my talk
this permits me to reassure the men in
the audience that the next time you
think your wife is a you should be glad
about it when you
go past your ego identity
there's a bigger identity that is
so huge it's incomprehensible it can't
even be described and there's a freedom
and a joy
that comes from that and
i had had glimpses of that but this
period of intense stillness and by the
way since then i've kept a week of
silence
every year sometimes i do more
and
that week of silence usually in
september i do every year
just to go back to the taste of
timeless being yeah instead of you know
our ego identity which we keep polishing
every day now especially these days the
key is that everybody is an independent
human being and you have to think as an
individual so that's why i say you know
no matter which house i grew up and i'm
sure that would have some impact on me
but i hope that as time went on i would
learn from life experiences and then i'd
start thinking as an individual not just
as my parents kid and not just as my my
wife's husband but but and not just as
you know a jewish guy but as somebody
who actually believes as an individual
in particular points of view and i think
you're starting to see that i think the
identity politics of the left is
starting to crumble a little bit because
it's become so restrictive you know this
belief that if you're a member of a
particular racial group that you no
longer allow to think outside the box or
if you're a member of a particular
sexual orientation you can't think stuff
that other people don't want you to
think i think a lot of folks are
starting to find this really restrictive
and galling and insulting and they're
starting to think okay well maybe i'll
take a look at some other stuff for
myself and when there are folks not just
like me but obviously people like jordan
peterson or sam harris or dave rubin and
people who are all over the map
politically but who are saying listen
it's time for you to take a look at the
data on your own and figure out for
yourself what you think that's an
empowering thing i'm not telling anybody
what they ought to think i mean i'm
telling them what i think but you're
you're a grown-up right you can make up
your own mind but that's the point you
are grown up and it's your job to make
up your own mind it's not your job to
follow what your parents told you or
what your racial group says you ought to
do a lot of people
have a misconception that rationality is
the ability to repress your emotions to
somehow subtract them from your
decision-making process and that is
exactly the wrong way to approach it
because
think of it in your own life if you meet
somebody who turns out to be very toxic
like a toxic narcissist
you're you're going to get a gut
reaction an emotional response from them
right this something's wrong with this
person and then that causes you to start
thinking about
maybe i shouldn't involve myself in a
partnership with this person maybe i
shouldn't get in a relationship so your
emotion will trigger a dangerous
response which was sort of the
reason why we have emotions a fear
response oh there's a lion hanging out
over there i better be you know aware of
it that emotion then triggers your kind
of awareness
so emotions are essential to the
rational process the problem is you have
no distance from your emotions you're
not able to take a step back and analyze
is this a rational response
is there really a lion over there well
you know i live in los angeles it's
probably not a lion over there it could
be a coyote or something right so i'm
able to step back and kind of analyze
the nature of the threat the nature of
what could be something exciting or not
so that's the dividing line the ability
to step back and analyze your emotions
and tell yourself
why am i feeling this way
why am i angry why am i excited
that is the key point that is what
divides people who are truly able to be
rational from those who can't be right
so
you have to train yourself it's not
natural to who we are because our nature
is to simply react right so
the ability to stand back and say no i
better wait maybe i should wait a couple
of days before i send it let's see how i
think tomorrow and then tomorrow shows
you that it was irrational that your
emotion wasn't really proportional to
the event so if your emotional reaction
is proportional to the threat or to the
opportunity then
you know then there's a reason for it
but so often particularly in this hyper
social media environment where it's kind
of like we're all feeling constant rage
and anger
a lot of times it's not related to
anything real or is out of proportion to
the actual problem or threat
so you you don't try and repress your
emotions you can't write a book you
can't start a business you can't make a
decision about what you want to do
without the richness of emotions the
brain is an organic thing everything
works together so people who have had
that damage where they can't
feel the emotion that the emotions are
blocked and there are brain damage that
causes that
it's been shown that they can't make
rational decisions because they can't
decide they can't feel
what is what is good or what is bad what
is an opportunity what is dangerous
so you want your emotions you need them
you're not trying to repress them
repressing emotions will lead to other
problems what you want is just that tiny
little bit of distance that ability
when you're feeling it
to go back and go hmm
why am i really feeling this what are
the roots of it that's very powerful
ability that you can use that you can
develop through practice
just like exercise will develop your
muscles through being able to think
before you react it will slowly become
natural to you but you have to practice
it you have to be aware of that's the
source of your problem
[Music]
if you want to learn how to change your
destructive habits check out this video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there i want to separate like
behaviors and emotions so usually when
people say they have they're having a
bad day
sure certain things may have gone wrong
or something that they tried to do you
know didn't work out